nous partons pour le village de brémont
en aval de tours installé en bord de
loire
il porte la marque d'un passé où le
fleuve était avant tout un moyen de
transport
nous y retrouvons stéphane vallières
architecte au sein du conseil
d'architecturé d'urbanisme de
l'environnement de l'indre-et-loire son
rôle ici est d'aider la mission val de
loire dans la compréhension du paysage
on a aussi tout un patrimoine qui est
héritée des siècles passés
un patrimoine construit pour la
navigation
on était plutôt dans un contexte d'un
fleuve qui était utilisé d'une manière
fonctionnelle et pas du tout sur une sur
des valeurs esthétiques la notion
d'esthétique mais récente nous son
paysage tout ça c'est des notions très
récente qui sont apparues au 19e siècle
même boire au 20e siècle et tout le
monde d'ailleurs ne partagent pas le
même point de vue sur la notion de
paysage le territoire classé au
patrimoine mondial et long de 2 181 km
il ne concerne pas que la loire mais
tout le val le lit majeur des limites et
souvent par des coteaux espaces et du
plusieurs centaines de mètres à
plusieurs kilomètres le paysage classés
et donc le fleuve la terre et le
patrimoine bâti un espace totalement co
construit par l'homme hérité de la
renaissance et du siècle des lumières
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt un espace
touristique un espace de détente fois
pour la population locale pour la
population pour angèle pour les
habitants l'eau et puis pour le tourisme
qu'on cherche
attirés aussi direction savonnières un
petit village proche de tour installé
sur le cher savonnières est typique d'un
lieu qui s'est transformé au gré des
usagers des moyens de transport marine
de loire puis transport routier on est
sur un paysage naturel et puis l'homme
bien s'implanter ou bien construire un
autre paysage fabriquer du patrimoine il
faut pas fabriquer du patrimoine à
l'origine su fabriquer des
fonctionnalités qui aujourd'hui prennent
naissance du patrimoine
d'où patrimoine unesco
tourisme urbanisme réglementations
diverses font que la vie contemporaine
influe grandement sur le paysage
ligérien
dans un objectif de préservation et de
développement la mission val de loire a
conçu un plan de gestion
ces plans de gestion c'est un ensemble
d'orientations qui qui dit par exemple
qu'il faut préserver les vues sur ce
paysage qu'il faut maîtriser l'étalement
urbain pour garder ces coupures entre
les entre les villages et à partir de
ces orientations chacun qui a une
responsabilité sur sur le territoire sur
l'aménagement du territoire doit
intégrer ces orientations dans les plans
locaux d'urbanisme dans les schémas
d'aménagement et ce terrain on est dans
un dans un village très caractéristique
que les guides 10 pittoresque qui n'a
pas de grands de grands monuments comme
villandry peut la voir avec son château
mais qui est très caractéristique par
son paysage par sa situation on est dans
un village qui est à proximité tour qui
est dans l'agglomération de tours sur le
plan administratif et donc qui subit une
pression urbaine donc un des enjeux
aussi c'est de gérer cette pression
urbaine la mission val de loire est une
petite équipe de 10 personnes qui
travaillent depuis 13 ans de concert
avec les différents acteurs du paysage
elle c'est l'attrait du label unesco
vis-à-vis du tourisme
mais ce n'est pas le seul axe de travail
quand le val de loire a été inscrit au
début des enfants en 2000 tout le monde
a dit mme cette inscription va permettre
de développer le tourisme alors ça a été
vraiment pour les collectivités un grand
enjeu
alors il ne sert pas qu'à ça je pense
que il sert aussi à préserver le cadre
de vie tout simplement des habitants
mais le tourisme est en effet un élément
important c'est le deuxième poste
économique en région centre c'est trente
mille emplois et donc des villages comme
savonnières
peuvent s'ils développent une politique
de qualité de préservation leurs
paysages et de leur patrimoine
avoir une attractivité touristique très
forte comment mettre en valeur les
caractéristiques paysagères
patrimoniales et naturelles
comment prendre en compte dans
l'aménagement le million d'habitants
ligérien comment enfin concilier
préservation développement social et
économique
les réponses à ces trois questions
permettront au val de loire de rester un
paysage culturel vivant mémoire de lui
même